explain to you how you can get your wife  to do whatever you want or get someone  to give you money who you're trying to  sell by using reciprocity when you're in  the persuasion process and they're like  i'm not really sure at that point the  person who gives first has the control  because you get to control how you get  reciprocated too and so that means is if  i want to go to a restaurant i might  give something to her earlier in the day  that's lesser than the restaurant later  but it still feels like tit-for-tat  because it's very difficult to quantify  an intangible like what is going to my  restaurant versus i took the trash out  and so if i take the trash and i can say  i'm going to where i want to go for  dinner it takes me five seconds to take  the trash out but we go to where i want  to eat for two hours humans can't  quantify that well if you give first you  get the upper hand and you can do the  same thing in sales